c'est l'un des événements littéraires de
cette rentrée le dix neuvième roman de
françoise sagan le chagrin de passage
chez plon julliard ce roman raconte 24
heures de la vie d'un homme de 40 ans à
qui l'on vient d'annoncer un cancer
incurable
on est loin du scandale provoqué par
bonjour tristesse il y a de cela
quarante ans monique atlan le sens de
tarte avec françoise sagan bonjour
monsieur aba'a pardon vous et j'ai le
rouge
bonjour madame chez lui via bonjour
monsieur
non mais non ça valait le choix de vivre
intacte sagan même que le présent
retour en arrière noir et blanc du temps
qui passe des images qui fixe une
cigarette
éternel et des éclats de vie si intense
qui l'ont souvent fait la une de
l'actualité
avec le recul le scandale et l'insolence
semble plus sage plus proche de
l'innocence celle de la jeunesse
quarante ans après bonjour tristesse
sagan ne cherche plus à déjouer les
clichés elle s'est simplement d'en tenir
compte et est vraiment considéré quand
même j'ai une starlette le stand
littérature justement est évidemment été
la fois des missions et du succès et et
pendant que un peu exagérée du comique
puis j'ai pu j'ai un mal fou en prendre
au sérieux il reste est à tomber
je suis pas certains reflex sans doute
une des tests un peu les ranchers des
tests de skis racistes sur une chose la
direction des taxis et des réflexions
allemand c'est votre cher même que le
dicton une espèce j'aime bien j'aime
bien les gens les gens m'intéresse même
jusqu'à la rue me gêne pas je l'aimais
pas l'écouter avec ses palais avec lui
et puis puis j'aime bien une pure bien
et ferrari
le style de vie comme un style
d'écriture mon cheval définir parce que
la petite musique la tête et si parole
elie finish possibles sur certains
actifs instinctif cette nonchalance
incertaine pudique
ce mélange d'ironie désabusé de
tendresse pour ses personnages elle
réinvente de livre en livre
comme elle ils vivent de ses chagrins de
passage comme elle aussi il s'attache à
une seule ligne d'horizon
on vient passer ni l'avenir par cette
parole
peut-être par nostalgie gants rapport
incite certaines personnes qui gémissent
ont disparu et au futur que tu peux rien
c'est aussi pour cet accent de sincérité
qu'on aime sagan